marketing de alimentos todo lo que es
también hay comercio internacional
que tienen oportunidades farmacéuticas
lo hacen a través
agrupaciones luego configuramos
cooperativas que les da una
poder de las fuerzas de compra y venta
también que para ciertos bienes sí
buen nombre experiencia como canal más
y ahí te llevó de punta a punta
del país has recorrido un largo camino
en burkina faso eres un experto
camino creo que por los conflictos
Pasé pero no, sí, rodé mi bache.
no esta mal tu uso estoy obligado a
sostén mis senos con mis brazos porque
que creo que se van a volar
estás en el auto y va a apestar
asi que pero estas dos aventuras llenas de
giros y vueltas ¿qué haces?
llega un día que vienes en un
ciudad uno voy eres el objetivo de
prácticamente disparos del ejército te tenemos
dispárale o qué pasó es un
protesta estudiantil que no fue
mal cuerpo y nos encontramos
desafortunadamente era la única manera
para llegar a uagadugú y
bobo-dioulasso o tan necesariamente
tuvieron que tomar este camino allí ellos
Fueron seis años que se partieron en el horizonte
es una especie de bloqueo porque ellos
demostrado contra el médico forense
quien habia dicho que dos estudiantes habian
han sido los objetivos de la meningitis porque si
fueron golpeados por la policía entonces
que estaban tratando de encubrir esto
evento y los estudiantes son
salio y tomaron parte dos
gary nuestro caso por caso en el fondo
es y ahí empezaron a saquear un
poco lo que teníamos en la caja de un
camión y nomura
salí un rato con los palillos
en las copas de vino estamos de acuerdo
con tu protesta pero no es un
razón de las cosas pies
y finalmente hay alguien que es
escuchó que encontró los efectos entre
señores en la caja un camión luego
nos dejó en nuestro camino
me gusta que me pase lo mismo aqui esta el
pueblo siguiendo el es mi cliente quien
n tenía los palillos esta vez
ahí y por fin pudimos continuar
pero reconozco que fue algo
cosa
pero por lo demás sí rodé mi bache no
mal tú siempre te acompaña yo
piensa en una guía cuando
caminar de un pueblo a otro
buscar soluciones para sus
productos a la venta estas cosas
nunca estás solo es siempre
alguien sabe el tema hecho para
para entrar en los pueblos uno puede
no suceda asi lo represento
tienes que ser presentado a estos pequeños
playa y por lo tanto mi cliente que
representó a esta asociación en
congelar faro una cooperativa para que
mango seco, marañón y otros
los productos iban a acompañarme
obviamente tenemos un conductor que
apoyar a los clientes con los que tengo
trabajado allí ahora proporcionar
causas del co2 en el mundo
es un eufemismo decir algo
si si entonces esta muy orgullosa de ella
realmente hay productos de
consumo que son muy interesantes
pero los problemas de transporte que
el burkinabè y el fondo no somos uno
sin salida al mar francamente precio algunos
ocasiones en que los precios son altos pero
buenas cajas o anacardos
rompemos y estamos listos para pagar
la diferencia pero en lugar de hacerlos
viniendo de burkina bord sale por venir
de otras partes de Asia donde los volúmenes
se habían reunido durante las empresas
low cost eligió ir allí para el
calidad de un escaner es lo que esta vez
tuviste un papel directo en esto
aventuras
aventura allí sino preparar al cliente para
frank lowy ah bueno porque tu quieres
ponerlos frente a sus
responsabilidades haciéndolas
entiende que está bien soñarte
producir pero también hay que vender
producción descontinuada
sí al hecho de que tiene un código de algodón por
ejemplo que el mundo ha vuelto a hacer y
taparrabos pero ahí me dieron
cómo mientras y necesariamente es necesario
buscando diversificar su producto que
tienen un criterio de diferenciación que
arreglárselas
podemos buscar valor añadido
pero si la nación acedia icc cuando nos
no necesariamente entender pero quien
cuanto tiempo y nos damos cuenta
que estas personas eran obviamente capaces de caminar
no tiene acceso a internet que nosotros
no es lo mismo y no nos importa
estaba saliendo si obviamente te tienes que ir
en las grandes ciudades
porque cuando estamos en el monte
pueblo pero cuando nuestro impuesto neto
crunch tampoco lo llamará
hay que pasar por la radio comunitaria
para obtener información entonces otra vez
así que sí, de hecho está en el
principales centros a los que acude
permisos internet pero nosotros que
permanencia a largo plazo esperada en tres
estrellas tienes que sentarte en una jaula
escaleras para estar mas cerca
posible ron eso es lo que te atrapó
traído para contar tus aventuras al día
el día al final de un día tú
siéntate a escribir lo que pasó
tengo que perder mas de años
burkinabés cien mercado que tendría
te da todo el trabajo que hay en
increíbles condiciones la temperatura
las herramientas con las que trabaja
Es una bota un cepillo con un
tal serenidad que ella tuvo que dejar ir
verde estar allí todavía de pie realmente yo
es un pueblo que admiro mucho